not everyone makes it out of the walking
dead alive the title of the popular
zombie drama could tell you that but the
most recent episode the penultimate
installment of season 9 features some
especially grisly deaths the left viewer
shocked spoilers ahead episode 15 of
season 9 the calm before revealed that
the whisperers and their leader alpha
killed 10 characters by decapitation
then stuck their heads on spikes and
organized them in a row if alpha does
not shoot herself then they escape this
is exceptionally brutal stuff even for
the walking dead but the three murders
that drew more gasps from viewers than
the others were those of terror Henry
and Enid both because their deaths prove
just how ruthless alpha really is and
because those characters don't die in
the original version of the storyline as
seen in The Walking Dead comics Ezekiel
and Rosita did after the episode aired
The Walking Dead director and
co-executive producer Greg Nicotero
opened up to The Hollywood Reporter
about the decision to kill Tara Henry
and Enid and the choice to deviate from
the comic book source material saying
when we break the story and when the
writers are in the writers room we don't
always know when an event is coming a
lot of times we'll find out at the very
beginning of the season where some of
the landmarks are but we had no idea who
it was going to be or when it was going
to be until probably two or three
episodes before we shots Nicotero says
that the deaths felt random and
uncontrollable because alpha didn't
choose to kill people based on any
personal vendetta against them
she killed to kill to send a message to
the people of Alexandria the hilltop the
kingdom a sanctuary and oceanside
Nicotero continued first of all the
deaths are at the hands of a human being
instead of walkers so that immediately
makes a difference it constantly
reminded that man's inhumanity toward
man is the most horrific thing that can
occur as a real brutality to it Nicotero
revealed that the creative team at the
think about how the deftness episode
would affect over characters and that
pushed them to pick Tara Henry and Enid
as he explained there is a very specific
reason to lose Henry due to his
relationship with his adoptive parents
Carol and Ezekiel as well as with Daryl
Dixon as far as Tara is concerned her
growing power at the hilltop influenced
a decision to kill her off and in a
somewhat similar vein Enid's too
in relationship with our doom was also a
motivating factor the critical consensus
regarding the brutal episode has been
positive with the den of geek calling
the calm before quote a stellar exercise
in taking a television show and making
it at like an event CBR called it easily
one of the best episodes of what's
become one of the Walking Dead's best
seasons thanks for the heads on spikes
sequence which is bound to impact the
future of the show in a massive way
meanwhile Nicotero commended alpha
actress Samantha Morton on her chilling
performance in the episode telling The
Hollywood Reporter Samantha has done
such an amazing job this season she's
seven bodies everything that the show
needs on once though these deaths will
likely leave a hole in the hearts of
many Walking Dead loyals
they do help to thin the very thick cast
of a series that isn't going anywhere
anytime soon
AMC has already ordered attend the
season of the show with CEO Josh sapin
saying in September 2018 that the
network plans to keep the Walking Dead
IP alive for another decade through all
sorts of media from the flagship series
to spin-off shows to films and
additional comic book issues cutting
down the number of characters on screen
is unnecessary evil as it will allow the
show to continue of finding its focus
moving forward we know it's difficult to
say goodbye to characters some of whom
have been around for years but perhaps
these 10 new Walking Dead victims had to
fall to their fellow apocalypse
survivors and flourish check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]